[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur figaro live
on est au figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous on attend vos points de vue
notamment ce soir sur le floutage des
policiers en intervention êtes vous
favorable à cette mesure proposée par
gérald darmanin on vous pose la question
sur twitter et on la pose ce soir
également à laurent joffrin dans soir
laurent on ait eu content de vous
recevoir la première ici sur le plateau
point de vue pas sur le plateau le
figaro live mais on rappelle que vous
êtes ancien directeur de libération et
fondateur d' engager vous engageant nous
engageons nous engage à vous parce que
on a engagé vous engageant nous et les
engagés donc il faut voilà donc max et
engageons-nous face à vous jean
christophe buisson directeur adjoint de
la rédaction du figaro magazine le
figmag qui fait sa une sur les escapades
pour prolonger l'été et on signale le
signe votre dernière oeuvre parce que
vous êtes trop modeste jean christophe
ouhayoun viennent de signer la semaine
dernière quand vous avez présenté cette
émission les grandes figures de la
droite c'est un ouvrage absolument
majeur qu'il faut lire qu'il faut
acheter
c'est un ouvrage collectif dirigé avec
guillaume tabard
en deuxième partie on reviendra sur les
mesures du gouvernement contre le
coronavirus si enfin jean castex a
commencé à parler il devait commencer il
ya cinq minutes mais pour l'instant ça
n'est pas encore signalé et c'est à
suivre en direct
si vous voulez c'est également sur le
site du figaro on essaiera de commenter
si elle est première mesure
et sinon bassila pas les premiers à
mesure déjà c'est ça donnera matière à
commentaire sait rien on va commenter
rien justement justement ce chien qui
trouvera sa experts un petit déjà boyer
et ils font du mauvaise et rien n'y fait
ils font déjà du mauvais esprit je sais
pas comment on va s'en sortir mais enfin
on est avec vous ou nous dit déjà ce que
vous en pensez vous répondez de quand
même à notre question sur sur twitter
également sur les forums du figaro à la
fois sur le site du figaro et sur la
page youtube
faut-il flouter les policiers en
intervention alors foutez comme aurait
dit monsieur de la palisse maîtres du
flou sur les visages des policiers alors
c'est la fonction filtres effets de flou
sur première
logiciel bien connu des spécialistes ou
blu-ray faict sur à vide
vous avez l'embarras du choix avec les
logiciels de montage
la proposition en tout cas vient et xoom
minister cela vient du lion de
l'intérieur alors il n'y a aucun
placement de produit je tiens à le dire
la proposition vient du ministre de
l'intérieur pas qu'ils aient pas de
placement de produit mais du floutage
des policiers on va on va y arriver
gérald darmanin donc un congrès syndical
on les écoute
demain je dirais aux crs et je dirais
aux gendarmes mobiles que je ne souhaite
pas qu'ils portent la cagoule dans les
manifestations
parce que la police de la république
elle doit pouvoir montrer son visage
même si je sais que c'est extrêmement
compliqué mais en même temps je vous
dois la protection et donc votre
disposition qui consiste effectivement à
interdire la diffusion des images
lorsqu'elle est extrêmement
reconnaissable je la fais mienne et je
la proposerai dans la proposition de loi
qui arrive d'ici la fin d'année au
parlement et le service après vente a
été assuré ce matin par la ministre
déléguée marlène schiappa là nous
parlons de quoi nous parlons des
policiers qui lorsqu'ils sont en train
de faire leur travail
son film est à 2 cm 2 devant leur nez et
on les filme à longueur de journée en
attendant et parfois même je le dis
pardon c'est la politiquement correct
mais parfois en espérant la bavure comme
on dit et en le filmant à longueur de
journée devant lui pendant qu'il est en
train de travailler ensuite c'est
diffusé sur les réseaux sociaux avec
parfois des appels au lynchage
donc c'est une mesure que nice de
l'intérieur mais à la discussion chacun
pourra avoir voix au chapitre les
syndicats policiers évidemment mais
évidemment les parlementaires et mendier
scrutera mais je crois que l'idée du
ministre de l'intérieur
j'en suis même sûr c'est de vouloir
protéger les policiers qui nous protège
alors je salue jean paul qui nous
rejoint sur le site du figaro jean paul
nuit n'apprécie pas vous n'appréciez pas
cette mesure jean christophe puisque
jean paul mullie c'est un paradoxe on
installe des caméras pour reconnaître
les gens mais en foot les policiers pour
ne pas les reconnaître
pourtant les actions des policiers
doivent être surveillés aux six mois je
paradoxalement je pensais mauvaise idée
paradoxalement parce que effectivement
je suis plutôt pour qu'on défende les
policiers dans cette affaire qui sont en
permanence menacés agressés attaqué
depuis depuis des années avec une
l'accroissement de cette violence anti
policière et de la parole anti policière
qui est assez effrayante mais je
trouverais que flouter le visage des
policiers est un tel aveu d'échec pour
un gouvernement qui remet tellement les
choses à l'envers de ce qu'elle devrait
être parce que je pense que toute
personne qui serait qui agréent serait
qui diffuseraient des images d'un
policier en appelant à l'agresser ou
toute personne qui agressent la famille
d'un policier devrait être puni point
final
c'est comme on est une société on ne
punit plus on fait les choses à l'envers
maintenant on est obligé de protéger ce
qui nous protège qui sont supposés nous
protéger les policiers de peur qu'ils
soient agressés c'est quand même c'est
quand même la version des choses il me
semble donc accepter qu'il soit floutée
pour les protéger
ça veut dire qu'on a perdu que les
policiers ne sont n'est même plus
capable d'assurer la sécurité publique
puisque les policiers sont eux mêmes
menacés c'est mais pourquoi pourquoi
c'est pourquoi on en vient à se poser
cette question pourquoi un syndicat de
police parce que c'est pas darman elle
propose il relaie une proposition d'un
syndicat de police donc les policiers
eux mêmes le demande il le demande parce
qu'ils ne sont plus ils ne se sentent
plus eux-mêmes protégés par la loi par
l'état par le par le par le ministère
dont ils dépendent puisque la
délinquance qu'il qu'il réprime la
délinquance qu'ils arrêtent
ça ne sert à rien puisque la justice ne
fait pas son travail derrière donc
effectivement ils baissent les bras ils
en sont à demander à être protégée parce
qu'ils ont l'impression que leur travail
est complètement décousu détricoter
ensuite par la justice ou par les médias
peut-être qu'on en parlera qui
évidemment exploits de ces images est
parfois pas pour des raisons purement
déontologique contrairement à ce que
prétend david dufresne qui lime
mais on fait ça parce que c'est pas pour
s'amuser c'est parce que les policiers
sont très violent très méchant il
atteint j'en ai l'instit qui
s'est spécialisé dans la surveillance à
ce qu'il appelle les violences
policières qui existent lors laurent
vous partager le point de vue de jean
christophe raisons différentes mais non
à la responsable est ce que vous dites
que c'est je pense qu'on sera les choses
à l'envers c'est un mauvais service à
rendre aux policiers pourquoi
en conclusion parce que le il ya des
fautes policière ça existe il ya des
erreurs il ya des violences il légitime
mais il ya des violences qui sont nés
dans cet esprit-là que c'est un ça
existe si vous flottez ça veut dire que
ces violences sont le fait d'un policier
anonyme
on connaît pas son nom donc c'est la
police en général mais c'est violent
comment son matricule et pas forcément
floutés oui enfin si si et matricule et
connu pourquoi pas le visage
on se demande pourquoi est il faudrait
qu'on me démontre qu'il ya de 300-400
agression de policiers qui ont été qui
ont uni a eu des représailles de tel ou
tel voyous tel ou tel délinquant contre
des policiers qui n'ont fait que leur
travail mais je crois pas que ce soit le
cas il ya des menaces vrai il faut il
faut s'en faut s'en saisir
mais encore une fois le lait si les
fautes sont individuelles je vois pas
pourquoi le ca n'apparaîtrait pas sur
les écrans en plus un argument
supplémentaire
c'est quand même très difficile à mettre
en oeuvre parce que vous il ya une
atteinte à la liberté d'informer et les
instances judiciaires se sont souvent
prononcer sur cette affaire et ont
considéré que le floutage l'anonymat des
policiers étaient étaient justifiés
quand il s'agit de terrorisme
dans le cadre dans le cas du raid dans
le cas de
le policier spécialisé dans le grand
banditisme
quand on a affaire à des gens comme ça
depuis toujours et enfin depuis
longtemps en tout cas les manifestants
c'est pas du tout la même chose ou le
maintien de l'ordre dans les quartiers
difficiles c'est par la même chose on
n'a pas affaire à des terroristes
on a affaire à des gens un peu violent
parfois beaucoup enfin la police est là
promet pour les contenus pour les
réprimer et encore une fois si vous si
vous dites tout policier qui est filmé
et qui est violent et protégés qu'est ce
que vous dites aux citoyens vous dit ben
voilà il ya une espèce de d'exception
fait en faveur des gens du maintien de
londres ce sera difficile à admettre
donc c'était par contre si on cherche
une solution
la bonne solution c'est que chaque
policier et sa petite caméra qui
marchent en permanence et qui permet de
filmer et de pouvoir contredire les
réseaux sociaux quand il accuse à tort
tel ou tel policiers d'avoir fait
quelque chose d'irrégulier ou de trop
violent c'est encore une fois c'est un
problème aussi juridique de liberté la
loi sur les libertés c'est que l' usage
l'utilisation de ces deux cd images des
caméras piéton est très réglementé elle
doit passer par je ne sais combien de
service pour être validée on en a le
résultat au bout de six mois donc là
aussi je pense qu'il ya quelque chose a
changé dans la loi mais dès qu'on touche
à ces lois là c'est vrai on est supposé
nous voulons toucher aux lois qui
protègent
qui protège les citoyens contre une
surveillance généralisée donc c'est très
compliqué il ya sûrement quelque chose a
changé
je suis entièrement d'accord la caméra
piéton est aussi une contre-preuve quasi
immédiate
sauf que il le demandait même absolument
à ce que je dis n'est pas contraire à ce
que dans l'argumentation en entendez
marlène schiappa tout à l'heure le dire
elle a défendu ce matin sur france info
avec beaucoup de gars avec beaucoup de
fougue 7,7 cette mesure notamment en dix
ans ce qui n'est pas normal aujourd'hui
c'est que des enfants des enfants de
policiers on est de dire que nos n'ont
pas honte mais ont peur de dire que leur
père est policier et ne marque pas sur
la profession du père qu'on leur demande
dans le formulaire qu'on leur demande à
la rentrée scolaire
bien sûr mais là c'est un problème plus
grave c'est un problème complexe qui est
qu'il la publicité néfastes qui fait sur
la police depuis des mois depuis des
années et qui est du seul manière
favorisée par certains par certains
journaux qui alimentent cette haine
haine du flic n 2 du gendarme haine de
la police
sans discernement je suis d'accord avec
laurent joffrin c'est pourquoi ont il ya
des cas individuels qui sont
condamnables qui sont parfois condamné
peut être pas assez mais mais on peut
pas généraliser systématiquement
aujourd'hui on parle des violences
policières de violence systémique comme
on parle de racisme systémique tout
devient essentialiser généralisée alors
que les moutons noirs et qu'il y en aura
toujours dans toutes les professions dit
compris la nôtre n'a sûrement à nous
trois qui est qui est un mauvais
journaliste à tous les coups mais c'est
ça ce n'est pas une raison pour
stigmatiser tous les journalistes c'est
ça qui est inquiétant dans cette société
où tout devient
encasernés dans une dans une définition
et on a laissé je pense dans certains
médias diffusés cette idée que le
policier était par essence violent qui
fait que effectivement son enfant à
l'école va être moqué stigmatisés parce
qu'en disant tu fais partie de cette
caste de cette engeance de ces gens qui
sont brutaux violents racistes etc
et là il ya quand même un discours de
discours à revoir à recomposer à ce
sujet j'ai un désaccord avec les gens
qui dénonce systématiquement la police
je suis contre ce genre de choses je
pense qu'il ya des lois il faut la
respecter et la police et d'incendié
libération il ya quelques une de
libération qui était pas tendre avec
will smith et sur des cas particuliers
voici ce n'est pas sur la police en
général on n'a jamais dit qu'il fallait
de commandes hier dénigrer la police en
général on a toujours fait en sorte que
on s'attache à des exemples précis et
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire peut-être
qu'on a pas réussi on peut se tromper
enfin c'est l'esprit le plus la police
sera respectueuse de ses propres règles
d'intervention qui existe il ya une
heure zoologie policière plus et
respectueuse de cette déontologie plus
la confiance entre la police et la
population quel que soit compris dans
les quartiers les plus durs à une chance
d'exister
et plus les sanctions à l'égard des
moutons noirs quand vous dites qu'il ya
plus elles sont précises bien étayé et
rap et plus les gens penseront que
effectivement la police fait son travail
et pas ou des choses et ça dépend pas
des policiers eux mêmes d'ailleurs ça
dépend de la hiérarchie mais ça dépend
du ministre qui donne plus ou moins
d'aidés des lignes de conduite des
ordres des directives pour réprimer de
manière plus ou moins violentes telles
ou telles manifestations
mme amy moie 1000e son pardon qui on n'a
pas assez dit aussi ces dernières années
les violences extrêmes qu'ont subis les
policiers notamment dans les
manifestations à l'époque de la loi une
connerie ça commencer plus tôt au barça
l'émergence de cette violence vraiment
extrême et qui a entraîné sûrement avec
des sabots mais même une violence
physique avec les fameux black blocks
certain que tout le monde condamne une
amie unanimement site qui se cumulent et
si tous les organismes les associations
s'occupent dénoncer les violences
policières pour est de temps en temps
s'occuper aussi de savoir on est bien il
n'y a pas quelques violences parmi les
manifestants oui mais par ailleurs ces
gens là vous répondre mais ces violences
des manifestants des black blocks et
sûrement des policiers qui font de la
provocation souvent on est dans cet
engrenage donc les policiers sont
perdants à tous les coups franchement
avec eux il ne prend pas de soutenir ce
point de vue plus vite et il en a ils
sont il ya des violences cette idée là
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que je ne
dis pas qu'à violences policières
s'explique par la par la violence des
manifestants mais s'il ya effectivement
une répression policière ci parce qu'il
ya eu des choses violentes qui ont été
commises avant les policiers ne fera pas
pour le plaisir des manifestants et même
des
les jaunes les excès et les excellences
illégitime mais c'est une réponse à l'ue
si c'est pas la peine de faire la morale
il faut objectiver il ya des règles
d'intervention si elles sont respectées
on peut pas dire grand chose au monde
qu'elles sont mauvaises mais en général
ces règles d'intervention et mistinguett
à joseph est une époque où on n'avait
pas cette ultra violence qui existe
aujourd'hui dans la police et parfois
non alors j'ai commencé maintenant je
suis d'accord dès lundi c'était très
violent mais ensuite ce sens qu'elle
quand même les milers années 80 c'était
très violent et le problème je pense
majeur ça vous ne me contredirait pas je
pense c'est que les services d'ordre des
mouvements politiques syndicaux etc qui
existaient n'existent plus ils sont
incapables c'est eux qui encadre les
manifestants eux mêmes syndicats le
syndic le les liens des services dans le
service d'à cgt inquiète pas leurs
filiales sont débordés les
manifestations sur le même texte sur la
loi comme read pardon l'association des
résidants qui se greffe sur une autre
monument national et parce que c'est
arrivé elle était là pour empêcher
justement ce genre empêcher les gars
j'ai pas toujours aussi de se mêler aux
manifestants du parti comme image
personnelle puisque on a découvert
notamment une des manifestations du 1er
mai
enfin c'était pas cette année ni l'année
d'avant mais c'était celle du demi 2010
est celle de 2017 dont celle d'anne
world un an avant on voyait bien à
retrouver un peu retrouvée les archives
sur fear alive
on voyait bien que la partie syndicale
était extrêmement tenue c'était bon
enfant c'était avec toutes été décadrés
calibre est attendu et devant le drame
c'est la meilleure des broussailles ont
découvert des groupuscules d'anti fac et
ce qui était extrêmement frappant
l'occasion exactement est vraiment à
chercher chercher à chaque fois la
confrontation avec avec les connaisseurs
les policiers sont même complètement
démotivée manifestement à l'heure
actuelle c'est ce que nous dit cet
internaute qui est au délicieux
pseudonyme d' archiduchesse si czm nous
dit la meilleure façon d'aider la police
c'est que les juges fassent leur taf
est ce que finalement c'est parce alain
aussi des problèmes puisque l'une des
plaintes des policiers c'est de dire que
quand ils nous arrêtent des délinquants
quand il notant qu'il réprime et bien ça
n'est pas suivi d'effet ou c'est même
démenties par les décisions judiciaires
c'est vrai il faut dire qu'il ya une
partie faussée une partie visuelle non
je dis la vérité
au delà de deux ans notre je vais
désormais très en deçà de rhodes non aux
femmes comme aux hommes et au delà de
deux ans de condamnations pour les faits
graves
les peines sont exécutées donc il est
faux de dire qu'elles ne sont pas
exécutées et on met paris au salon de ça
alors je déclare tel sujet on distille
dans l'opinion l'idée que le type qui
poignarde sa famille non non non pas
faire sortir les plus graves sont toutes
exécutées 92%
c'est en dessous que deux enquêtes une
voix d'ailleurs qu'elles étaient passées
non pas par la gauche mais par la droite
cvc et rachida dati qu'à passer une loi
qui est qui a passé d'un an à deux ans
les conditions pour aménager les peines
donc là c'est vrai que dans cette
hypothèse là quand c'est moins de deux
ans ça peut recouvrir des faits assez
grave de 18 ans vivant à l'horizon pour
une agression et la pression est assez
violente bon et là le type et condamner
les yeux noirs il sort libre parce qu'il
faut attendre que le [ __ ]
le juge de l'application des peines se
prononcer ça prend des mois donc pendant
des mois il est libre et donc le
évidemment la victime va sortir un type
qui vient de l'agresser il n'ya pas
longtemps la puissance délivrée à jour
il fera peut-être sa peine il l'a fait
les en général
en général ils sont exécutés mais c'est
des peines aménagées c'est pas de la
prison dans la majorité des cas donc il
faut réfléchir c'est ça le si on cherche
une solution réfléchir à cette question
de l'aménagement des peines est-ce que
c'est est ce que ce sont des fausses
peine est ce que quand on dit travaux
d'intérêt l'intérêt général bon ça passe
et ça ne pose aucun problème ou
délinquants quand on y brasse lettre
électronique
est ce que c'est une peine ou pas une
peine ou est-ce qu'il faut remplir les
prisons qui sont déjà pleines de gens
qui sont condamnés à moins de deux ans
voilà la question dans cette vocation
plus confiante et mon accord qu'elle en
a l'air mais convenez que par exemple si
la récidive était était déjà beaucoup
plus pudique et ne l'est aujourd'hui
parce que ce que vous dites vous pouvez
récidivé à nouveau être condamné et pas
jusqu'à deux ans les policiers ce qui
les fait le plus souffrir c'est de
croiser des délinquants qu'ils ont
arrêté cinq dix quinze vingt fois pour
des faits mineurs ce que vous appelez
pas grave et qui sont fictives
objectivement moins graves
non mais en moins grave que les
assassinats mais qui sont quand même qui
participe de cette atmosphère de cette
ambiant et du sud découragement des
policiers en tout cas le débat est âpre
sur le forum du figaro louis combes ie6
ne voulait un peu plus il est pas un peu
plus âpre en tous les cas il est
illettré nourris et les arguments
tournent autour d'un côté de ceux qui se
plaignent de certaines violences qui
sont notamment commises au sein au cours
de manifestations comme les gilet jaune
si on avait flouter les policiers qui
ont abusivement utilisé leurs lanceurs
lbd nous dit jean paul il y a des
strokes des estropiés qu'il n'aurait
jamais eu gain de cause que ça babineau
babineau qu'on connaît sa rue et qu'on
calcule ses meubles et bien un autre
fidèle
vous verrez vous le retrouverez les
contrats suivants qui va faire que ce
sens avec babineau seach également
qu'ils sont des internautes fidèles
kriss kross également qu'on salue c'est
contre productif et c'est aussi un aveu
que le grain est une citation c'est
contre-productif et c'est aussi un aveu
que le gouvernement a perdu la bataille
des images non c'est pas des gens quand
ça arrive c'est soit désintéressé la
communauté figure la communauté point de
vue c'est contre-productif donc nous dit
babineau et c'est aussi un aveu que le
gouvernement a perdu la bataille des
images et la question ça qui est
intéressant aussi c'est d'habitude les
réponses aux questions que l'on pose
sont assez tranché eh bien là c'est
beaucoup plus partagés êtes vous
favorable au floutage du visage des
forces de l'ordre en intervention et je
vous êtes 57% à répondre oui mais 43% à
répondre non
et le débat continue le souci étant
qu'on a envoyé tout ce qu'on avait en
leur disant carte blanche pour tabasser
les opposants politiques mais dit si tu
m'en sors voit bien que le débat
s'enflamme
je rappelle un peu rapide je vous
propose même si ça n'a pas commencé ça
commencera dans un peu plus de cinq
minutes maintenant de revenir sur la
position du gouvernement par rapport aux
à la crise du coronavirus on attendait
donc des mesures qui devaient être
annoncées à l'issue d'un conseil de
défense avant d'y revenir je jouais
savoir juste comment vous interprétez la
séquence donc il est 17 heures 23
normalement
jean castex de parler depuis une
demi-heure conseil de défense a duré
trois heures et demie on annoncer une
prise de parole en fin de matinée puis
en début d'après-midi par olivier
ferrand puis olivier ferrand à 16h puis
en négligeant castex à 17h et la bombe
maintenance à 17h30
est ce que je reçoive ce que jean
françois delfraissy à 22h je propose de
soumettre sa dans les débats justement
de la refondation de la gauche
jean françois delfraissy a pas raison
finalement c'est difficile de prendre
une décision
oui c'est parfois difficile la fois
c'est quand même leur travail là c'est
bien peu bizarre que ça soit constamment
reporté fout mal comme on dit c'est
tellement l'image de la gestion de cette
crise il est totalement inédite par le
gouvernement on a un sentiment en
permanence d'une valse hésitation il ya
eu tellement d'erreurs de communication
il me semble depuis depuis le début
encore une fois on peut pas leur jeter
la pierre de manière massive comme un
policier par un manifestant parce que
une situation tellement inédite qui
était quand même très compliqué mais
mais en impression qui maintenant ils
attachent presque plus d'importance à la
communication qui va être fait
les éléments de langage qui on a donné
pour justifier les décisions qui vont
être prises
c'est plus important que annoncé
effectivement ces décisions à laquelle
nous sommes suspendre auquel nous sommes
suspendus depuis depuis des heures et
c'est un mauvais calcul parce que ça ne
fait que nourrir de sa manière chez les
français l'impression d'un saut mis ko
d'indécision de peut-être se disputent
deux effectivement la disputer entre la
mini dispute entre le conseil
scientifique et macron qui a recadré
delfraissy cavell
les laisser entendre que c'était un
petit peu lui qui avait décidé ce qui
allait se passer est assez symptomatique
de cette ambiance étrange
eh bien en attendant jean castex je vous
propose justement de revenir sur 7 sur
ces accusations de coup d'état
sanitaires qui ont été lancées sous
jacent l'encontre du conseil
scientifique et voici la réplique
justement ce matin de son président jean
françois delfraissy
au micro de sonia mabrouk sur europe 1
je suis je suis un grand démocrate
c'est évidemment les politiques qui
décident on est là pour les aider
chacun son rôle et en aucune façon en
aucune façon il n'y a eu ni l'envi n'est
une tentative de pouvoirs publics
ni envie ni tentative de pouvoir médical
vous le croyez moi je suis assez
d'accord moi je suis pour eux je suis
pour une gauche des solutions
c'est-à-dire que quand on propose
quelque chose il faut se mettre à la
place des gouvernants et comme vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs la crise est
totalement inédite donc on peut
comprendre que des incertitudes
hésitations de difficultés de ceux là
mais à partir de là je constate quand
même pour défendre le processus qui
s'est déroulé je ne pense pas que ce
soit le conseil d'orientation en
question qui décide je n'ai jamais rien
d'essayer du taux il a pouvoir de
conseil donc d' influence mais il n'a
pas le pouvoir
à chaque fois qu'on comprend une
décision au niveau de l'état il ya des
règles on se tourne vers le ministre en
livrant monsieur le ministre on fait à
mont fébé à vous de décider
alors donc on est vidé ont fait à la vie
du célèbre jeu 10 heures oui mais le
conseil 100 km et ses conclusions
laissent entendre que si vous choisissez
b où vous emmener à la mort des dizaines
de milliers de personnes dont quatre
fois ci c'est vrai on n'en sait rien
c'est ça le problème
oui d'accord mais à la fin des six sont
divisés ou s'il ya hors du conseil
scientifique des gens tout à fait
valable qui disent le contraire
le ministre est obligé est bien content
qu'ils écoutent oui bon d'accord et il
décide
derrière une sorte de voile d'ignorance
mois il faut bien quelqu'un décide c'est
jamais le conseiller scientifique qui
décide c'est toujours pourquoi commencer
décision est mauvaise passe mal c'est de
sa faute à lui il peut pas dire c'est la
foi de contact oui alors justement
pourquoi quand la décision est
manifestement mauvaise les gouvernés et
gouvernants ne disent pas on n'en sait
goury en a pris ma décision
les masques on a dit qu'il en fallait
pas parce qu'on en avait pas et non pas
parce que c'était pas bien la preuve en
est que six mois six mois plus tard
c'est ça qu'il faut faire c'est les
tests non ça sert à rien puis maintenant
il faut en faire enfin ce point je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est quand même de
leur grand mère placée et puis surtout
un centime il à faire d'un raout aussi
éclairé ça c'est
la chloroquine c'était la mort non la
chloroquine c'est pas la mort c'est
peut-être pas la solution idoine mais
c'est pas la mort est présenté comme si
c'était la mort évidemment on écarte
didier rahout deux assiettes et recruit
pardon dj set de cette décision c'est
bien que je pense que l'orientation du
conseil scientifique me paraît quand
même assez
reviens revient à donner une certaine
consignes au gouvernement qui après n'a
plus tellement le choix dans do do
l'enthousiaste de monsieur delfraissy
qui donne un moment assez sûr de lui
mais les médecins ils ont prêté le
serment d'hippocrate qui sont là pour
défendre la vie des gens et ils sont pas
là pour évaluer les conséquences
économiques et sociales d'une décision
qui préconise ça c'est au gouvernement
de le faire c'est lui qui doit prendre
ses responsabilités oui et c'est
tragique puisqu'il faut décider entre on
va sauver le maximum de gens qui te met
les l'économie par terre où on va le
sauver moins de gens ont sacrifié donc
pour éviter tous les problèmes sociaux
notamment qu'on va avoir 6 l'économie ça
existe des solutions qu est ce qu on
avait préconisé pas même pas le je pense
que aujourd'hui je pense que il faut il
faut tout faire pour éviter leur
confinement tout faire parce que c'est
une catastrophe
le roman généralisé ou même partiel même
partielle si vous re confiner les
grandes villes c'est comme si vous
arrêtiez l'économie ça revient au même
il faut tout faire pour éviter ça c'est
désagréable mais c'est transitoire il
faut respecter strictement les gestes
barrières et les consignes qui sont
données et arrêter de dire que c'est
compris les masques au bureau mais il
sait utiliser ces des discussions
subalterne
en fait je comprends concédé à moi j'ai
remporté un masque et comme tout le
monde et ça m'énerve mais bon
il faut choisir moi je suis pour un
gouvernement rationnelle quel est le
danger principal c'est que les connu
l'épidémie leur part la pandémie soit
très forte qui ait un engorgement des
hôpitaux qu'on commence à craindre
d'avoir à choisir entre les malades on
en avait eu des bagues à six mois c'est
le même du mag des six mois qui a été
tranché d'ailleurs puisqu'on a fait le
confinement et il faut éviter ça il faut
éviter d'arriver là c'est ça le danger
majeur
il ya une hiérarchie des risques donc le
risque majeur c'est celui-là parce que
si ça se produit il y aura une nouvelle
récession il sera encore aggravé la
récession laquelle est porteuse de mille
maux sociaux y compris de mordre y
compris les des atteintes à la santé
publique
donc il faut éviter ça à partir de là je
plaide pour une espèce de civisme
généralisée qui fait que l'on respecte
si on porte le masque et qu'on respecte
les consignes normalement ça jugule
l'économie et la fin de la pandémie est
normalement contenu par ses gestes il
faut les respecter
pourquoi pourquoi je lui fais mais juste
pourquoi on a le gouvernement a décidé
de généraliser l'obligation de porter le
masque parce que au départ c'était libre
on disait vous portez le match quand
c'est dangereux et portait pas quand
c'est pas dangereux
seulement on a vu dans quand on en avait
je parle de l'époque on en avait déjà et
on les portait ou pas on voyait bien
qu'il y avait des groupes de gens de
toutes générations et de toutes les
origines peu importe qui se réunissent
et sans précaution donc il donc le
rallye bombard va interdire le bas c'est
absurde il ya on a fait les choses à
l'envers parce qu'on s'aperçoit que dans
la rue et quand même le risque est
beaucoup moindre
ouais en force bien des gens le porter
dans la rue et les gens ils pendant la
rue ils sont forcés et parce qu'ils sont
surveillés ils ont les la monture banon
quand il arrive chez eux qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils l'enlèvent et c'est là
où ils oublient les gestes barrière
c'est là où ils se réunissent avec leurs
grands parents
et c'est là où le virus circule depuis
deux mois c'est parce que c'est interdit
et bien justement vous ne pensez vous
pas que le gouvernement fait les choses
à l'envers au lieu de 10 rebonds dans la
rue c'est quand même moins risquée si
vous n'avez pas dans une rue très
fréquentée
donc quand vous êtes sur le champ de
mars effectivement que vous croisez vous
voyez quelqu'un a dit mais vous n'êtes
pas obligé d'avoir un match en revanche
dès que vous arrivez chez vous des
xavier en lieu clos
ces masques y systématique la mer c'est
ce qu'ont fait les grecs de les grecs
ils ont
mais 100 fois moins de morts que nous
ils ont fait ça pendant les grecs c'est
pas un peuple plus disciplinée du monde
les allemands le rend bien assez
reproché là les grecs ont réussi ça
pourquoi parce qu'ils se sont
disciplinés ils ont fait preuve de
civisme que vous vanter mais je vous
trouve un peu naïf en pensant que les
françaises sont encore civilisé c'est
vrai c'est ce que c'est votre charme
d'ailleurs ou pas là
l'autre question que ça c'est un autre
débat il ya l'autre débat éviter le sur
la naïveté on peut demander à un lionel
jospin mais on va pas faire débattre de
sa ce soit j'espère qu'il y aura un
confinement à paris nous dit kris kross
par contre si tu lis j'espère au moins
que nous autres à la campagne ne va pas
se bouffer du confinement à gogo alors
que les problèmes sont dans les sons
dans les villes parce que ça aussi le
gouvernement en généralisant en refusant
la territorialisation justement du
confinement je pense à amis les gens
dans cette danse est dans cette panique
à l'idée d'être confiné pourquoi on n'a
pas fait des lois une régionalisation du
confinement c'est ça aussi qui a rendu
les gens fous et qui rend encore les
gens fous qui rend les gens paniqués à
l'idée d'être confiné qu'aujourd'hui on
se pose la tension panique vient pas des
gens elle vient du fait mais ces
objectifs qui fait visiter notre projet
ici s'arrête l'économie oui quand vous
arrêtez l'économie vous déclenchez des
problèmes sociaux et non moins c'est ce
qu'on allait voir que c'est ce que dit
cet autre internaute là mathieu qui est
absolument d'accord avec vous de le pire
c'est c'est leur confinement si vous
avez des nouvelles des preuves de vie
vous pouvez me le donne et nous sommes à
la recherche d'un certain jean castex
devrait parler depuis matignon est pour
l'instant comme vous le voyez
la journée qu'on ait terminé notre débat
comprendre la période à tripoli
on est prêt à exceller à regarder malgré
le plaisir qu'on a tendance est dans
cette conversation mais j'aimerais bien
que justement avant peut-être que le
premier ministre devait prendre la
parole
on commente que babineau encore je
trouve l'atmosphère en france
terriblement anxiogène et le rôle ambigu
du conseil scientifique n'aide pas ce
qui est intéressant c'est la perception
justement on y revient de ceux de ce
conseil scientifique et dans les prises
de paroles qui peut avoir et les
déclarations qui peuvent être faites à
l'issue du conseil scientifique ou par
certains de ses membres
justement l'impact qu'il ya sur
l'atmosphère anxiogène qu'il ya autour
du coroner virus mais c'est anxiogène
parce que c'est dangereux c'est pas le
gouvernement qui a organisé la peur pour
l'espèce de paranoïa comment c'était un
sentiment d'insécurité
c'est une affaire de sécurité sanitaire
les sacralités logo parce que nous on a
tous dans notre entourage des gens qui
ont été malades ou qui sont morts donc
je vais pas accepter cette affaire comme
sérieuse et donc les gens sont craig
c'est normal on peut pas pas reprocher
aux gens trinquier de ce virus qui
édifie très difficile à contenir
manifestement puisqu'il est le nombre de
contaminés ne cesse d'augmenter
nick est un problème le je crois pas que
sais je suis papa d'an et paranoïaque
mais je ne pense pas que le gouvernement
organise le la peur pour contrôler les
citoyens je n'ai pas chez orwell en ces
temps une démocratie et le gouvernement
seraient bien contents si ça s'arrêtait
cette affaire et pour passer à autre
chose ne fait pas exprès de le diffuser
l'inquiétude c'est pas vrai ça c'est des
des fantasmes des extrêmes de droite ou
de gauche nord mais je pense que ce qui
inquiète les gens aussi c'est ils
entendent bien ils voient bien que les
scientifiques parce que ce virus est
quand même assez particulier ne sont pas
d'accord ni sur le diagnostic ni sur
leur mène et que quand il ya un conseil
scientifique qui décrètent des choses se
disent mais sur lesquels sur quels
médecins il se base sur quelles études
puisque les indices haussier les eyzies
solar est pas le conseil balle en
l'occurrence on a l'impression que c'est
comme les conseils de scientifiques qui
pousse les ministres à prendre une
décision comme macron a décidé d
confiner le conseil était plutôt contre
on va
maintenant puisque jean castex
visiblement nous a entendus et donc il a
pris la parole
vous pouvez suivre en direct la
déclaration du premier ministre qui
vient d'enlever son masque sur le perron
de matignon
et nous on se retrouve lundi même heure
même endroit merci laurent merci jean
chri et vous remettez votre masque et en
attendant vous pouvez acheter le figaro
magazine pour savoir ce qu'ils aient
dernière escapade à faire et les grandes
figures de la droite
les escapades une des grandes figures de
la droite ou s'il peut être tous les
ouvrages sur napoléon de branges aux
français qu'on recommande à très vite
sur funny or die